a prime minister just five weeks into
office today put himself on a path that
could see him the shortest-lived prime
minister in history if things now go
wrong if there's one thing that can hold
us back
in these talks it is the sense in
Brussels that MPs may find some way to
cancel the referendum if they do they
will plainly chop the legs out from
under the UK position and make any
further negotiation absolutely
impossible and so I say to show our
friends in Brussels that we are united
in our purpose MPs should vote with the
government against Corbin's pointless
delay I want everybody to know there are
no circumstances in which I will ask
Brussels to delay we're leaving on the
31st of October no ifs or buts at the
top of the road outside the gates chant
throughout an uncomfortable backdrop for
the PM determined to persevere
it's vital negotiators get on with their
work without that sword of Damocles over
their necks and without an election
without an election
I don't want an election you don't want
an election you could be forgiven for
being confused the PM doesn't want an
election that could get MPs to vote on
one anyway
no wonder coming out of Downing Street
came a degree of Battlement are we going
to have an election mystery spot
remember election threats I think the
only thing I remember him saying is he
doesn't want an election so perhaps it's
a million-to-one chance of election then
you know that tomorrow's rates looking
very dicey we're heading for election
absolutely confident we can win the vote
Sam and absolute every confidence in the
Chief Whip today saw an alcohol-fueled
charm offensive by Boris Johnson less
than 24 hours after he threatened to
expel Tory rebels like Philip Hammond
and Ken Clark it was political
acrobatics the processor inside
Westminster rather than those on the
streets are the reason for the crisis
it looks like Boris Johnson's government
cannot stop a rebellion to halt a No
Deal brexit he is a majority of one of
as many as two dozen of his own side
could be voting in the opposition
lobbies tomorrow increasing pressure
today a letter from ringleader rebel
Philip Hammond pushing the Prime
Minister on progress suggesting they
don't really think he's trying hard
enough for a deal it's now clear several
of Teresa Mays most prominent cabinet
ministers have gone beyond the point of
no return mr. Gault you might be defying
the whip for the first time in your
political life tomorrow you might be
barred from standing in any general
election within a fortnight and out of
Parliament within a month or so how do
you feel tonight well it's been clear
for some time the these weeks in
September and October were going to be
dramatic they were going to be crucial
and some big decisions were going to
have to be made and I've been wrestling
with that for some time so at some level
I'm not surprised to find myself in a
situation similar to the one on that I
mean but I think in the end I've got to
vote on the basis of what I think is in
the national interest but he's not alone
it's thought that between 19 and 25
conservative rebels are willing to defy
the whip that's lose their jobs to vote
against the government tomorrow if he
takes the way you won't be able to stand
if there's a general election for the
Conservative Party will you know but I
feel so strongly about this that I'm
prepared to put my job on the line for
my constituents I will be sorry to be
told I have to leave it rather than for
it to be my choice
but I'm a grown-up I understand what the
rules of Parliament are it's just
slightly surprising that it's applied to
me after years of loyalty but how
exactly do they intend to do it draft
legislation to force Boris Johnson to
delay brexit of a deal hasn't emerged by
October the 19th now published by the
rebels what our bill does is to say that
if by the 19th of October the Prime
Minister hasn't been able to reach an
agreement with the European Union and
the council meets the two previous days
or somehow hasn't been able to persuade
Parliament to agree to leave the EU
without a deal on the 31st of October
then he will have to apply for a further
extension MPs aren't formally back from
there some
holidays yet by the end of this week
they could have triggered a general
election there's nervousness on all
sides some Tory MPs worried that Boris
Johnson is attacking the conservative
coalition with his threats to expel
Philip Hammond and Ken Clark two
prominent former Chancellor's some
Labour MPs simply worried that Boris
Johnson might prove more popular in
Jeremy Corbyn labor reform they want an
election but they fear any maneuver by
Boris Johnson that could cut polling day
after October the 31st mininum automatic
no da brexit we must come together to
stop no deal this week could be our last
chance we are working with other parties
to do everything necessary to pull our
country back from the brink then we need
a general election today Downing Street
had yet another new inhabitant Dillon
the dog with rebellion looming perhaps a
canine is indeed a more reliable
companion than the party he needs we'll
find out tomorrow whether Dillon and his
master will be gambling their futures on
Downing Street on an election Sam Kate
sky news